Our scripture reading for this morning comes from Exodus chapter 17 starting in verse 8.
Then Emilech came and fought with Israel at Refideem.
So Moses said to Joshua, choose for us men and go out and fight with Emilech.
Tomorrow I will stand at the top of the hill with the staff of God in my hand.
So Joshua did as Moses told him and fought with Emilech.
While Moses, Aaron and her went up to the top of the hill.
Whenever Moses held up his hand Israel prevailed.
And whenever he lowered his hand Emilech prevailed.
But Moses hands grew weary so they took a stone and put it under him and he sat on it.
While Aaron and her held up his hands one on one side and the other on the other side.
So his hands were steady until the going down of the sun.
And Joshua overwhelmed Emilech and his people with the sword.
Then the Lord said to Moses write this as a memorial in the book and recite it in the ears of Joshua.
That I will utterly blot out the memory of Emilech from under heaven.
And Moses built an altar and called the name of it the Lord is my banner.
Saying a hand upon the throne of the Lord.
The Lord will have war with Emilech from generation to generation.
Now we'll go to Acts 18 starting in verse 5.
Jethro, Moses' father-in-law came with his sons and his wife to Moses in the wilderness
where he was encamped at the mountain of God.
And when he sent word to Moses, I, your father-in-law Jethro, am coming to you with your wife and
her two sons with her.
Moses went out to meet his father-in-law and bowed down and kissed him.
And they asked each other of their welfare and went into the tent.
Then Moses told his father-in-law all that the Lord had done to Pharaoh and to the
Egyptians for Israel's sake.
All the hardship that had come upon them in the way and how the Lord had delivered them.
And Jethro rejoiced for all the good that the Lord had done to Israel.
In that he had delivered them from out of the hand of the Egyptians.
Jethro said, Blessed be the Lord who has delivered you out of the hand of the Egyptians
and out of the hand of Pharaoh and has delivered the people from under the hand of the Egyptians.
Now I know that the Lord is greater than all gods because this affair they dealt arrogantly
with the people.
And Jethro Moses' father-in-law brought a burnt offering and sacrifices to God.
And Aaron came with all the elders of Israel to eat bread with Moses' father-in-law before
God.
The next day Moses sat down to judge the people.
And the people stood around Moses from morning till evening.
And Moses' father-in-law saw all that he had, all that he was doing for the people.
He said, What is this that you are doing for the people?
Why do you sit alone and all the people stand around you from morning till evening?
And Moses said to his father-in-law, Because the people come to me to inquire of God.
When they have a dispute they come to me and I decide between one person and another.
And I make them know the statutes of God and his laws.
Moses' father-in-law said to him, What you are doing is not good.
You and the people with you will certainly wear yourselves out for the thing is too heavy
for you.
You are not able to do it alone.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray together.
Lord, thank you for the gift of your word.
And Lord, I pray that you would give us a posture of attentiveness and humility before you
that we would be looking to you with hearts that are ready to receive what you would
have to give to us through your word this morning.
And that we would be just even now submitted to you saying, Lord, whatever you would say
to us, our answer is yes.
Lord, I pray that you would teach us by your word now.
In Jesus' name, amen.
Well, as children get older it's wild to see how quickly they grow.
I know one of the ways that parents and sometimes grandparents will kind of mark out their child's
growth is by literally taking, say, a pencil and having their child stand up by like a door
frame and mark their height along the wall or on the door frame.
And I know I have a vague memory of my grandparents' house, at least starting doing that, you
know, where they're marking my height on the wall.
But I've got a very vivid memory of when I grew as a teenager, Alton hit a growth
spurt.
I came running into my grandparents' house.
Right near where that wall was, as I ran around the corner, my head hit the very door post.
And so it marked me instead of me marking the wall.
And so I was right there on the floor.
So growth in, let's say it this way, physical growth isn't the same thing as growth in
maturity.
I think we all know that.
And the thing about growth in maturity is it's harder to think of, well, how do
you measure growth in maturity?
What does it even mean when we talk about growing in maturity?
Well, one way to think about it is to say growing in maturity is moving from being passively
cared for by others to taking on personal responsibility even to the point of caring
for others.
Right?
So it's moving from passively being cared for to actively taking on responsibility
even to the point of caring for others.
To go back to children, it's going from being spoon fed, to being able to feed yourself, to
being able to take part in like clearing the table after you finished eating and then
eventually getting to the place where you're one of the ones who's helping to put food
on the table.
Right?
That kind of maturing process.
Moving from being a passive recipient to an active participant in your family, in
your community.
Over the past couple of weeks, we've been seeing how the Lord brought His people into
the wilderness to train them so that they might learn to trust and to follow His word.
But another way of saying that is to say that He brought them through the wilderness to
grow them in maturity.
Right?
So this people is born and now they're growing.
And as that happens, we see them transitioning from merely being passive recipients to
being called upon to take on some personal responsibility.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, if you look back in Egypt, they were simply passive recipients of redemption.
And there was no other way that that could be because it was God who rescued them from
Egypt.
It was God who defeated their enemy.
It was God who set them free.
It was purely upon them to receive that redemption by faith.
In the wilderness, God is the one who is still providing for His people.
We've seen that over the past two weeks, but He's doing this in a way that's slightly different
now because He's also going to teach them to take on personal responsibility, to take an
active role in the community He is forming.
In many ways, this is really a picture of the Christian life.
It's how God works in redemption today because God saves us by His grace.
He saves us from sin and death, and that's something that we simply receive by faith.
After that, God sanctifies us by His grace.
It's not like, oh, it's entirely on us now to grow in the sanctification process, but He
does this in such a way.
He sanctifies us in a way that actively involves us in the process.
So it's a work of God, but, say, take Philippians chapter 2 and verse 12, for example, we're
called there to work out our own salvation with fear and trembling.
It's not to say that we save ourselves.
We're working out what God has worked in, right?
So God saves us, and we now live out this life that He has given us in Christ.
It's not always easy, but it's not something that we have to do alone because we mature,
we grow together as His people in Christ-likeness.
I love Philippians chapter 1 and verse 27.
That's really where the title, if we take a title for today, has come from.
It says this, that we were called to strive together side by side for the sake of the gospel.
So we take an active part in this community God is forming called the church, that we might
grow together and go together with the gospel.
So Exodus 17 and 18 gives us a vivid portrayal of what it looks like to strive together
for the sake of the gospel.
You see the Israelites face both external and internal battles, and the Lord sees them
through it all.
So I want us to take a kind of bird's eye view of these two chapters and see three lessons
that will hopefully help us to grow together in Christ-likeness, to strive together for
the sake of the gospel.
So first of all, if we're going to strive together, we need to remember where the
source of victory is.
The source of victory is something we see here.
So let's start in verse 8 there.
You see this is the first time that Israel has faced an enemy since Egypt, and last time
God did all the fighting, but that's not how it plays out this time.
So they're called upon to fight.
So who are they fighting?
Well, as we see that they're attacked here in verse 8 by the Amalekites.
Who are they?
Well, this is this nomadic group that are known for their hostility, and they're
an enemy that Israel is going to have to face repeatedly.
And they were particularly ruthless.
So you actually find out a little bit more about what happens here if you look at Deuteronomy
chapter 25 verses 17 to 19.
There we read that they were attacked at a time of weakness.
And not only that, they were attacked from behind.
So what the Amalekites did is they came up from behind and took out the most weak
and vulnerable among them.
You can imagine the sorts of people that might be a bit further behind who were
struggling to keep up.
And that's who they took out.
They didn't fear God.
And so Moses and the people rise up to this challenge and they engage in this
battle.
So how do they fight?
A couple of things.
One is they fight together.
So you get to verse 9 where Moses calls upon Joshua to then gather other
men to fight alongside him.
Now, as an interesting side note, this is the first time we're introduced to
Joshua.
And Joshua is going to have to go on years later and fight many battles
with Israel.
And he's the leader that's going to be the successor of Moses, who's going to
lead God's people into the promised land and they're going to fight battles
together.
So in many ways, this is this early preparation for Joshua, taking on
responsibility in this way to fight together with God's people.
What's Moses going to be doing while they're out there fighting the
Amalekites?
Well, Moses tells them he's going to, uh, he's going to go up this
hill and he's going to take Aaron and her with him as well as the staff of
God.
But you can imagine, this might seem like a way to get away from the
battle.
I mean, you can imagine Joshua maybe thinking, so you want us to go out
and fight and you're going to go up on that hill and you're going to be
watching us fight this battle.
But as we read, we see that what Moses does is actually a crucial part
of the battle.
In fact, the battle hinges upon what takes place on that hill where Moses is.
You see, when he gets up there, we read that he lifts up his hands and he's
got that staff with him.
So he's lifting up this staff and as long as he keeps it lifted up, Israel
prevails.
But as the staff, as he gets weak and the staff starts to lower, the
Amalekites, they start to prevail in battle.
Now remember, this staff is a symbol of God's presence and God's power
among them.
So they're being called to fight in the battle and yet the battle isn't
going to be one according to their strength or their strategies.
As Moses holds up this staff, it's like a banner reminding them that the
battle belongs to the Lord.
So they fight together, but they also fight in God's strength.
In other words, God is the source of victory.
It comes through the Lord who empowers them for the battle.
And by the way, although it doesn't explicitly say that Moses is praying
here, lifting up your hands is a posture of prayer that is mentioned
repeatedly throughout Scripture.
And it's put there before it says that as an embodied expression of
dependence upon the Lord.
And that's what's happening here.
As Moses' hands are lifted, they are dependent upon the Lord to
give them strength for the battle.
All right.
So the Lord is giving strength, but notice we come back again as you
move through the passage by the time you get to verse 12, where human
responsibility comes here again.
As Moses is starting to get weak, his arms are dropping and they
start losing the battle.
And so the people are going to get wiped out.
So Aaron and her go and grab a large stone and they put it
under Moses as a seat so he can sit down there and rest.
And they come along beside him and they start to lift up his
hands together in battle.
So they're striving together in the strength of the Lord that's
happening on the battlefield and that's happening up on this
hill in the place of prayer.
So we might ask the question.
Just just think about this.
Is God fighting the battle or are the people?
And the answer is both.
The people fight, but it's ultimately the Lord who gives the victory.
It's interesting that soldiers in that day would often rally around a
banner that would be held all off.
As they lifted up their eyes to the hill and saw Moses lifting up
this staff, it was like that banner that the soldiers would
rally around.
In fact, after the battle is won, Moses builds an altar there
and he calls it.
You see that in verse 15, the Lord is my banner because it
was under the Lord's name that they fought, that they gathered, that
they prevailed.
And this speaks to how we fight our battles.
So we might say, well, what does this tell us about the battles
that we face against spiritual darkness in our lives and in our
day?
It shows us that we strive together, but we do so in the
Lord's strength.
This is not a call to let go and let God.
It's a wonderful bumper sticker or, you know, magnet you can put on
your fridge, but imagine if Moses let go and let God here, the
staff would have fallen here, but neither is it just a call to
grit your teeth and live right.
Now God saved you.
Now you go out and do the right thing.
It's neither one of those extremes as it were.
It's a call to depend on the Lord for the strength to stay in
the fight.
So to go back to Philippians chapter two, verse 12, it says,
work out your own salvation, but then you get to Philippians two
thirteen.
It says, work out your salvation for it is God who is at work in
you, both to desire and to do that, which is pleasing to him.
So it's a fight.
It's a struggle.
It's one that we need each other in, but it's also one that
the Lord gives us grace for.
So we fight in his strength.
We lift up our eyes, knowing where our help comes from.
And I can't help but going back to this thing.
We've been going back to time and time again in Exodus and seeing
echoes of it in the life of Jesus.
What's the hill that we look up to where we see Jesus?
Well, it's Mount Calvary.
There we see the victory that he won on the cross.
And we also lift our eyes up to where he's at now.
We lift our eyes to the heavenly throne and we see that there
we have an intercessor who is greater than Moses.
Christ is risen.
He is the perfect mediator who represents us before the father.
And unlike Moses, he never grows weary.
Hebrews 7 25 says that he ever lives to make intercession for us.
So we keep our eyes fixed upon him.
You know, when we say the Lord is our banner, we can also
say Jesus is our banner.
Isaiah chapter 11 verse 10 says this about the Messiah who would come.
It says in that day, the root of Jesse, that's the Messiah, that's Christ,
will stand as a banner for the peoples.
The nations will rally to him and his resting place will be glorious.
So it's in Jesus' name that we gather and strive and prevail.
It is through our union with Jesus that we are connected to the power
that we need to live the lives that God has called us to live together.
It's in his name that we pray and receive strength for the battle.
OK, so that's the source of victory.
It's in the strength we have in Jesus.
But also as we strive together, we don't just strive together
with us that same source of power, but we also strive together
with the same ultimate goal in view.
Now, the Amalekites are defeated here, but this is not the last time
we're going to see the Amalekites because there's a continual battle
that's going to take place with them.
And here we see that God's judgment is on this people, the Amalekites.
But ultimately, the purpose of what is going on here and throughout
the rest of the book of Exodus and the whole of Scripture is not God's
judgment upon the nations, but rather God's plan of salvation for the nations.
So where do we see that here?
Well, once you get to chapter 18, so you've got this foreign nation
who's who's fought against and defeated.
But now when you get to chapter 18, we have the arrival of Jethro.
What's that have to do with anything?
Well, Jethro, remember, is a Midianite priest, right?
So he's not an Israelite.
He's he's from Midian.
So he's a foreigner, just like the Amalekites.
And he's he's also Moses's father-in-law.
And this this encounter plays out very differently when Jethro arrives.
When he arrives, Moses is is glad to see him and he welcomes him
and they check in with each other.
But as they check in with each other, Moses begins to tell him
about all the things that the Lord had been doing in their midst.
You see that in those first verses, all in chapter 18, all the way down to verse nine.
He tells them about how the Lord saved them.
He tells them about how the Lord had miraculously sustained them in the wilderness.
But notice what happens by the end of it, by the time you get to verses 10 and 11.
By the time Moses has gotten to the end, recounting the salvation that God has brought about,
Jethro is now rejoicing with Moses over what the Lord has done.
And this isn't just a I'm happy for you kind of rejoicing.
I like I'm glad this works for you, Moses.
No, he is praising the Lord by name.
So what does he say?
He says, Blessed be Yahweh, the Lord, the I am who I am.
Blessed be the name of the Lord, who has delivered you out of the hand of the Egyptians
and out of the hand of Pharaoh and has delivered the people from under the hand of the Egyptians.
Now I know that Yahweh is greater than all gods.
This appears to be a genuine confession of faith, even a genuine conversion.
And this is a significant moment that we might easily miss if we're just kind of
breezing through Exodus.
This is really significant here.
And if his confession isn't enough to demonstrate where Jethro is at spiritually.
Notice what happens by the time you get to verse 12.
Jethro offers a burnt offering and brings sacrifices to God.
And Aaron came with all the elders of Israel to eat bread with Moses's father-in-law before God.
So he is joining them in worship, bringing sacrifices,
fellowshiping, breaking bread with his people before the Lord.
So what's so significant about this?
Well, one commentator pointed out that this is really a microcosm of what the whole book is about.
Because remember, what is the point, the bigger picture of Exodus?
Remember, God's stated that his aim is to make his name known to Israel,
that he might make his name known through them to the nations.
Right? So God's aim is making his name known to the world.
And this is what is happening here.
A man from another nation is now praising God with his people.
This is in miniature what God is aiming to do through the Exodus and through
the greater Exodus that Jesus came to bring about.
So let's see how this applies to us.
Jethro's worship here.
Well, one is the good news has reached us just like the good news traveled to
Jethro and Jethro came to Moses to hear more about it.
So the good news has traveled to us here on the other side of the world
to where this has happened.
And here we are praising the Lord's name.
And then in a moment, we're going to break bread together at the Lord's table,
remembering his sacrifice for us on the cross.
All right. So we strived side by side together because the Lord has saved us
because we've heard this good news, but also we strive side by side
with God's ultimate purpose in view.
You see, our ultimate purpose as a church is to not only know the Lord's name,
but to make his name known both locally and globally to the ends of the earth.
We're part of that global purpose that God is fulfilling.
And so like Moses, we should love other people who are outside the faith.
Here you have this man who's from another culture, from another place,
even another faith being warmly welcomed here.
And I think, well, is that something we should do?
I think the answer biblically is absolutely.
I mean, when you look at the ministry of Jesus, I mean, he hung out
and ate with all the wrong sorts of people, didn't he?
He was known for welcoming sinners and eating with them.
And you look at passages like Galatians, chapter six and verse 10,
we're told that as we have opportunity, we should do good to all,
especially those who have the household of faith.
Notice it didn't say exclusively do good to those who have the household of faith.
But that's where we begin.
There's an especially category there, but that's not where it ends.
Sure, we should welcome one another, but we should also love those who are
outside the faith as well.
We should look for opportunities to make the love of Christ known to them,
whether that's family or co-workers, neighbors, friends, whatever.
We should also seek to do that amongst people who are from other parts
of the world where they might not hear the gospel.
And so that will mean going to those places and supporting those who go to those places,
but could also take the form of welcoming people here who are from other parts of the world.
I mean, that's that's true in Alabama.
It could be serving migrant communities who've moved here, who are in our midst here
and seeing that gospel opportunity that comes with that.
And just to give you a heads up here in a few weeks,
we're going to have a wonderful organization who's going to come
and share with us about how they are doing that here in Birmingham
and look and ways that we can be involved in that as a church.
Do an amazing work loving people in Jesus' name from all different places
around the world who are living locally.
So loving people and treating them with respect is essential,
but we're to do that with this in view, making Christ known to them,
not just in our actions, but also with our words as well.
You know, a few years ago, I met a guy and got to know him a little bit.
And he was from Indonesia.
He's a Christian man, but when he arrived in the U.S., he was not a believer.
And he at one point started working at a restaurant and he was he was waiting on tables there.
And as he's waiting on tables, this family took a particular interest in him.
And they remembered his name and they would get to know him when they would come
into the restaurant and that eventually got to the point where they were sharing
their faith with him as well and reading scripture with him.
And he eventually came to faith in Christ.
And now he has moved from where he was.
He was living in Knoxville, Tennessee, now back to Indonesia.
And today he is serving as a pastor in that difficult place in the world,
where there are very few believers and some of the peoples that are there.
And all of that goes back to a family who wasn't just focused on their meal,
but the one who was serving them and seeing the opportunity
they had to minister to somebody from another place.
And now he's making Christ known in that part of the world.
So we show love to people with no strings attached.
But we do so in the genuine hope that they too would come to know the Lord
and the eternal salvation that is found in him and in him alone.
We hope that they will pray join us in praising the name of the Lord.
Who knows how the Lord will use us when we keep his global purpose in view
as we strive together for the sake of the gospel.
So we strive together in the Lord's strength.
We do so according to his purpose.
And then lastly, I want us to see this.
We do it according to his perfect wisdom.
And here's what we particularly see here.
We see the wisdom of shared ministry.
We strive together, applying the wisdom of God and how to go about ministry.
And that's a shared ministry.
So what happens in the second half of Exodus 18?
Well, we're given a window into a day in the life of Moses's ministry.
And it is exhausting what he is doing there from morning until evening.
He would sit judging the people.
And I don't mean judging like the two guys on the Muppets who are sitting
on this beside the stage kind of making fun of the Muppets that are down there.
No, he was he was hearing cases where people had these disputes,
these arguments with each other, but also people who just needed to be
taught the truth that God had revealed to him.
And there were lots of things that he was be talking with these people about.
So he was teaching, giving counsel, settling disputes.
I mean, he was handling everything.
Makes me think of I didn't realize this until recently,
but you know, with the Wizard of Oz, I've seen that like dozens of times,
probably in my lifetime, but it's only a couple of years ago watching it.
Then I didn't realize that I don't know if you've ever seen this,
that the wizard who's on the Wizard of Oz is also the gatekeeper.
And he's also the guy who drives the carriage.
And then he's also the guy who's the palace guard as well.
And he's the wizard, too.
And this is what we see in Moses here.
Like he's, he's carrying out all these different roles in the life of Israel.
And remember, there are hundreds of thousands of people,
and he's trying to bear the load of it all wearing all these hats.
Maybe you know what it's like to wear lots of hats at the same time.
If you've ever been part of a church plant before,
you probably know what that is like.
Well, Jethro, his father-in-law is looking on.
And it's obvious to him that this is not sustainable.
So he tells them that Moses, this is going to wear you out.
I mean, this is a good work that he was doing,
but he was not going about it in a good way or certainly not in the best way.
This was far more than one man could do.
Now, the super spiritual among us might say, well, the Lord gives strength.
The Lord can give him the power that he needs to do what he is doing.
But know this, the Lord, who strengthens his people,
also gives his people supernatural wisdom.
And sometimes that can come from a brand new believer
who's just got a bit more experience in the world
and can see the wisdom of God's design that's all over the place in his good grace.
And so the Lord gives Moses supernatural wisdom through his father-in-law, Jethro.
Jethro is almost like Aaron and her holding up Moses's weak arms,
but he does this by giving some practical organizational wisdom.
So he wants Moses to prioritize the main things.
You see, then, verses 19 and 20, he wants Moses to, yeah, keep praying,
keep coming to the Lord and keep fulfilling the ministry of the word, Moses.
Keep praying and teaching the word for sure.
But also, you need to organize as well.
You see that in verses 21 and 22.
Divide the people up into smaller groups of hundreds and fifties and tens.
And then identify not just men, but godly men who can bear the burden with you,
just like Aaron and her did.
They could deal with cases in these groups of varying sizes that they oversee,
and then they could bring, say, harder cases to you when more support is needed.
All right, so prioritize and organize.
And it's interesting, when you get to verse 23,
you know, he points out, this is going to be better for everybody.
This is going to be better for Moses.
This is more sustainable for him, but also it's better for the whole congregation.
It's going to foster more peace in the congregation.
You see, Moses is going to be able to prioritize the prayer and the ministry of the word, more so,
and other leaders now in the congregation are going to be able to use their gifts together as well.
And no doubt, more people are going to be ministered to in a more timely manner.
Imagine the bottleneck.
You know, no doubt people were kind of lined up for a long way, and they maybe never got seen to.
It's just going to be so much better to move from this kind of one man ministry to a shared ministry.
So you have this pattern of wisdom, the wisdom of shared ministry.
You see this pattern repeated in the New Testament in the ministry of Jesus.
You know, so Jesus ministers to big crowds of people, crowds of disciples,
but then what does he do?
He calls 12 men whom he names apostles.
You see Jesus prioritizing prayer and the teaching of the word, but he also gives these apostles
responsibilities that they are carrying out.
There's actually one occasion that could even be a throwback to Jethro,
and that's the feeding of the 5,000.
I'm not saying it definitely is, but go check it out, see what you think, because Jesus,
when he's going to feed the 5,000 first, he could have just given them all the food,
but instead he gives it to the disciples, and he breaks the crowd up.
It tells us into hundreds and to fifties, and then he gives his disciples bread to feed
these different groups that are there.
But you see a pattern that's here.
So Jesus is going to minister to the crowds through the work of his disciples,
through these apostles.
He's going to pour into them, and they then pour into others.
So there's a pattern of discipleship here.
There's a shared ministry.
Now Jesus could have done it all, but he's teaching something about this pattern of ministry that he
has laid out.
Another way you see this in the New Testament is the principle of plurality when it comes to
leadership in the life of the church.
So you look at a place like Acts chapter 6, you see that same kind of wisdom of Exodus 18
there when the apostles are now sharing the load of ministry with other godly leaders
that they might devote themselves to exactly like Moses to prayer in the ministry of the word.
And throughout the New Testament, places like Acts 14, Titus 1, we could go on to many other
places.
We see that when churches were planted, elders, plural, elders were appointed to
lead those churches together.
So it's a principle of plurality.
You see Christ is the head of the church.
The church isn't built around one man unless that man's name is Jesus.
He is the head of the church.
And the way Jesus governs his church is through his word, but also he has designed the church
to be led by a plurality of godly, qualified men who care for his people and lead them,
especially through the teaching of his word.
And this plurality of leaders called elders aren't the only ways we see that kind of principle
of plurality being carried out.
We see other kinds of leaders.
But also when you get to Ephesians chapter 4 verses 11 to 16, we're told that God gives
leaders to the church to equip the saints for the work of the ministry.
So it's not even just on that kind of plurality of leaders.
It's all of God's people who work together in the work of the church.
People who work together in the work of the ministry.
They strive together side by side for the sake of the gospel.
You might call this every member ministry.
So it's Trinity just apply it to ourselves here.
As we grow and become more established as a church, we must apply the wisdom of
God's word under the direction of his spirit, even in how we organize ourselves.
Now structures and systems are not the point.
It's probably not what you came to hear about this morning.
Tell me, tell us about structures and systems.
Like they are not the point, but if wisely applied, they can play a vital role in
enabling us to strive together for the sake of the gospel.
They're an important part of gospel ministry to steal an illustration from a well-known book,
The Trellis and the Vine.
These structures and systems, this applied wisdom that God's given us in his word,
are like a trellis that supports the vine, the living element of the church as it grows.
So the church is an organism, but it's an organized organism.
Both have an important part to play.
You know, just to say in the early stages of a church plant like ours, it is more,
let's say, organic than organized.
And that is okay.
That is a genuine reflection of the stage we are at, the stage of developments as a church.
And I think the Lord, we don't have the crowds that Moses had to deal with.
So we're not yet at the stage, we have hundreds of thousands to organize here.
At the same time, let's not make the mistake of missing or downplaying
the role that organizational wisdom plays, because God has given us some instruction in
his word in this regard.
He's given us these patterns so that we might strive together, not just
in the immediate, but over the long call.
It's how he sustains us together as his people.
So a couple of application points related to that.
One is, let me encourage you to get plugged into the systems of care and discipleship
that we already have in place in the life of the church.
Now fellowship can happen outside of those systems.
So let's look for every opportunity to care for one another and to serve one another.
However, the Lord puts that before you.
But we've also established home groups already in the life of the church.
And I'm so thankful for the godly home group leaders that have been raised up already in the life of this church.
And the opportunity that home groups give so that we can care for one another and build community
together and make Christ known together.
So avail yourself to that if you're able.
But also secondly, let's be praying together that God would raise up a plurality of elders in our church.
So, you know, we're still connected back to the eldership at Redeemer.
I'm still connected with them.
But in the near future, our hope and our prayer is to appoint a plurality of elders here.
And we're already taking steps in that direction.
So let's make that a matter of continual prayer as a church.
We would follow the Lord in that matter too.
But let's all aim by grace to be active participants in this church rather than simply recipients.
Let's look for opportunities for fellowship, for partnering in the gospel.
Let's grow together that we might serve alongside one another for the name of Jesus.
Christ has brought us together into this body and I'm so thankful to be part of this church
that he is building.
So let's pray that he might teach us to strive together in his strength for his purposes and
according to his wisdom.
Let's pray together.
Lord, we need you so desperately.
And Lord, we thank you that you are the one who saves us.
And Lord, we thank you that you are also the one that gives us the strength
that we might come alongside one another, that we might grow together in the likeness of Jesus.
And so Lord, I pray that you would continue to grow us together as your people here.
Lord, as we do that, Lord, I pray that our eyes would not be upon ourselves,
but that our eyes would be fixed upon you because you are the one who is doing this in
our midst.
So Lord, I pray that you'd help us to take our place in striving together for the
sake of the gospel.
I pray this in Jesus' name.
Amen.